today's topic today we're gonna clean up
the infection we're gonna tell the truth
mr. Manziel in your lie detector ties
you were asked did you have any contact
with any of your three daughters you
said no and the lie detector said there
was no deception yes thank God how does
that feel for you and that your
daughters knowing well family our way
being on you felt they always did
knowing and didn't speak it because they
didn't know no matter they was told I'm
different miss Yvonne took a
lie-detector test and said did you make
up or exaggerated any stories with the
intention to harm Manziel she responded
now and the answer was deceptive you
have to be a pretty evil person to not
only keep your kid's father away from
his kids with a lie
but to make up a lie this heinous that
will destroy someone's reputation it
takes a very special kind of evil
mistakes are made people can mess things
up but when you lie and you maintain
that life for years and years and years
while someone else suffers and you do
nothing to change that Wow then he asked
you did you say something to the effect
of I'm gonna make sure you're never
happy again
she responded no and the answer was
deceptive so miss Yvonne has
acknowledged that her he doesn't feel
bad at all this is my guess looking at
her face so Miss Yvonne has acknowledged
that her story about you was not true so
Miss Yvonne is anything that you wanted
to say to mr. Mansell why didn't you
fight for I'm harder if you knew exuse
knew it don't you
I asked you for that reason listen
this happens more than you think it does
I've seen woman trying to get back at
the man they had a relationship because
they felt hurt through their children
I've seen this many many times many
times have I seen woman get it even for
our hurt that they received already
perceived in a relationship through the
kids not letting the kids see their
father being extra difficult I've seen
that they weaponized what weaponizing
kids I've seen that happen not even
saying that there's not a time that
there's bad people bad man out there but
I've seen that we're good people more
than often because they just want to get
back they want to be vengeful so the get
this idea in the head of their kids that
the man and the father is a horrible
person and better yet they feel betrayed
when the kids actually try to have a
relationship with the father solely
trying to ruin that I've seen that
unfortunately I've seen that too many
times it didn't even matter where they
were from I've seen that numerous times
unfortunately that's a common common
theme
you know it's interesting watching that
is how calm he is but also how I know
you must be angry there's nothing you
could do when you are falsely accused
and that hangs over you and people
question your character for something I
know what that's like I know how even
now I think that's why I kind of like
because I flashback to when I got that
angry and I still get angry thinking
about that time the anger he must feel
and his must be exponentially worse
because he was in a way made to look
this way in front of his children family
France you know for me was just a work
situation but god damned if it was my
whole life and to be or something even
worse like that your own kids as well
man that's a hard one to watch yeah and
what is it that he could have said hmm
that would have made you not believe the
lie you were telling miss Yvonne you
told the lie it was a lie and you told
it and you got an own ex I'm sorry I
need you to say that you did not your
girls I need to hear it come out your
mouth the way I've always heard him up
and the way she steps in time for that
the apology needs to be as loud as the
disrespect because now it was just a lie
detector that said it no I want you to
say to men I apologize for choosing you
and them please forgive me and if you
don't get out of here with that
rinky-dink apology I'm already our
Stokeworth I'm already not a fan of
apologies and these kind of
circumstances because nothing you can do
gonna do to her I'm not forgiving the
person who accused me I want nothing to
do with them I don't wish them any he'll
but stay away from what this but this
was an insult it's like you slapped him
in the face again because you didn't
really acknowledge his experience you
apologize because you had to
you don't have to forgive all of that it
was yes would you fit you know gives the
in song he can't physically do anything
yeah you know what I mean if he does
something physically he loses as a man
if he loses everything there's not gonna
be any forgiveness nothing even though
he was persecuted and said and lied to
and turn his kids turns against him
there's nothing he can do
how many times have we watch these kind
of shows and the woman gets up and slaps
the man he knows he can't touch this we
know nothing I cannot accept your
apology because it's not sincere deep
down I know that you know that you
didn't believe it you knew I had no to
desire from my children for 25 years
this thing has broken me
[Music]
you don't know it has effect in my life
in ways I can't even can the things that
you did this is not no game this is
these children's lives and it's just a
beam in you that you need to deal with
people are entitled to mistakes like I
said earlier but you keeping up a lie
for this long while someone else's
suffering
says a lot of bunch of characters not
demons it's not angels it's not no
supernatural bad person listen he just
said it the calmest way he could so and
you know you're gonna be able to say
that I heard people other people and I
get that and even if these apologies
whenever I hear apologies like that not
like what she said but in these
situations oh you know I mean I did some
mistakes it's not the person I am
it is it was part of you it's the person
you are and that unfortunately I've seen
too many times too many times and I know
I received a lot of flak when I said
that never say it again
sometimes a toxic mother is worse than
an absent father and it's not a reach
out there to the good mothers to people
to actually do their jobs single mothers
and do their job they're saying about
you
this ain't your fight I don't want to
see you in the commentaries because
we're not talking about you
we're talking about those people's right
there that do stuff like that
the problem is there's too many the
problem is a lot of people who do stuff
like that don't think they're bad people
just like she did say why didn't you
fight for them soon as if it's his
is his father that was his that
was him and you know if you turn and use
and weaponize you children against your
spouse mmm you're a garbage human being
you're really quick to take a check but
you won't check yourself for
accountability I don't say about this no
no there's not gonna be good that's
gonna come out of there this is people
always talk about you have to forgive
people I don't believe in that I don't
believe I don't believe I have to I have
to forgive people I don't I don't have
to hmm
stuff would it be done like that man she
fell on a good man a good man
stuff like listen I get it you know if
someone slaps you turn the other cheek I
get it but when someone rips off half
your face it's hard to turn the other
cheek when you don't have any left
that's what she did to this man and on I
don't you right I don't want to harp on
this for too long
nope maybe you guys got different
thoughts and you disagree if you do let
us know how would we want to hear your
thoughts in the comments below that was
hard to watch
No
[Music]
you